[Music]
what is happening oh my god no
what no
holy oh [ __ ]
god yo that is the most brutal thing the
mcu has ever done
easily
holy moly cannoli
wow welcome back to new rock stars
marvel studios what if episode 3
actually delivered the what if scenario
the sickest minds have been asking for
years what if ant-man popped someone
from the inside what if what the heck
this is inside marvel or after show for
marvel's what if on disney plus i'm eric
voss my easter egg breakdown is coming
out next on the channel right now we're
reacting to this episode's big takeaways
and not just hulk popping there's
another bombshell i think many of us
missed that in this universe hope van
dyne was actually killed by the winter
soldier
what after still coming off the high of
uh the spider-man no way home trailer
i'm back discussing this episode of what
if with mt
dude what is going on this episode was
crazy uh pretty much like almost as
crazy as the trailer but you know
definitely not as crazy as trailer but
it was pretty nuts i loved it what a
week we are in right now right it's our
big week i haven't even had a chance to
digest any of this and now marvel's uh
spoiling my lunch by popping hulk at us
it's upsetting but i'm very much
enjoying this
um just to recap this episode we revisit
the events of fury's big week that was
iron man 2 the incredible hulk and thor
where everything kind of is set around
the same time uh but here we see
avengers getting killed off one by one
natasha accidentally kills tony stark
hawkeye accidentally shoots thor and
then himself dies mysteriously bruce
banner now in mark ruffalo form because
edward norton never happened
but good for him because uh now hulk
completely inflates and explodes
then natasha gets killed and then it
escalates to a standoff against loki in
the forces of asgard but then fury
realizes that this is all the doing of
hank pym
now a yellowjacket villain getting
revenge for his daughter hope dying on a
past mission and things end with fury
defrosting steve rogers and joining
carol danvers because loki has taken
over earth and they need someone to open
the big guns but why is it more likely
than not that the winter soldier bucky
barnes was the one who killed hope van
dyne in this uh this universe's past uh
well before we get to that question our
merch partners at epic hero shop just
dropped a shirt based on spider-man no
way home the first in a series called
tales from the multiverse so you can
check out that shirt and our most recent
latest obsession shirt based on what if
over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you do that
you will open up the added option to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of these videos we
got elias who asks who do you think will
be the one above all in the mcu keep up
the great work hmm i think in this i
think kevin feige is the implied one
above all i think it'd be really cool if
they made him like the actual one of one
above all because they would fit uh
jeremy asks you think the silver surfer
can be introduced in what if after all
him and the watchers have history you're
right they do
um i would just be a bit surprised to
see the characters that marvel only
recently reacquired the rights of making
their mcu debut in this animated series
as opposed to some big exciting live
action forum but what do you think of t
yeah majorly agree i feel like a silver
surfer introduction would happen on the
big screen and then would come into the
animated form
yeah uh and then rodney asks what if
tommy became red hulk well i think tommy
is red hulk he just isn't telling us
exactly he's like you never shows us
when he's angry
yeah he's always very chill well what
was our big question coming out of this
episode mt well eric what if the winner
soldier bucky barnes was the one who
killed hope van dyne right so as natasha
romanov works to uncover the mystery
killer this episode she accesses a
shield file and realizes that someone
had logged into the server using the
account of a shield agent who died two
years earlier and then she gets attacked
and leaves fury this voicemail screaming
it's all about hope she's the key am i
too soon i'm mixing franchises i
apologize uh it's just a bit similar um
well nick fury deduces that hank pym
must be the murderer he's still grieving
the loss of his daughter hope from a
past shield mission and fury now works
with loki to entrap yellow jacket hank
and defeat him but during this scene
fury loki says
agent hope van dyne was killed on a
mission outside odessa ukraine ah odessa
it's a very interesting choice to
include that city in ukraine it might
sound familiar because in captain
america the winter soldier natasha
romanov told steve rogers about a past
odessa mission from around the same time
where she ran into the winter soldier
five years ago i was escorting a nuclear
engineer out of iran somebody shot out
my tires near odessa the winter soldier
was there i was covering my engineers so
he shot him
straight through me i think the
implication is that in this universe
hope van dyne was nick fury's go-to
operative before natasha and that hope
was sent on this mission to extract this
iranian nuclear engineer but then it was
hope that ran into bucky barnes and hope
did not survive that gunshot oh which
odd if that is the case that would also
mean that hope was either allowed to
work with shield by her father at one
point or she defied her father's wishes
to work with shield and became the wasp
much earlier in the timeline and if the
winter soldier killed the wasp that
would mean hydra got earlier access to
pymtech to this nanotech oh my god yo
that would be nuts and like obviously a
game changer like absolute game changer
and like of those two scenarios that you
just introduced i feel like the latter
would be more likely because her dad did
not want her anywhere involved with
anything after the loss of her mother so
like he wanted her to be safe so she was
probably like dad leave me alone i'm
gonna join shield and then he got killed
hence why he's upset so yeah exactly and
that's really the what if of this
scenario is what if hope van dyne
decided her dad was full of crap and
wanted to avenge her mom in her own ways
it's like um it's or not revenge but
like following her mom's footsteps you
know it's almost like what if the marvel
cinematic universe actually did begin
with wasp as an og avenger as she was in
the comics you know that's that's kind
of the secret what if of this episode um
but it's interesting of course you'll
notice hank pym is using the yellow
jacket armor kind of like how he becomes
the villain yellowjacket in the comics
um but in the movies that was something
darren cross designed he built on hank's
research uh but perhaps here losing hope
caused hank to go into business with
darren cross earlier
or just decided to build his own more uh
weaponized version of the man armor much
earlier um and then it was more willing
to link up with these hydra buyers
because remember that's what darren
cross was doing and hydra might have
actually helped hank hack into those
servers because think about it hydra was
really running shield at this time
anyways it was all zola's algorithm that
was pulling the strings of it okay okay
okay i see this i like it so i think the
true conspiracy of this episode mt was
hydra through the winter soldier killed
a shield agent slash avenger the wasp
vandyne and then that makes hank pym
snap and return to his nanotech research
which hydra steals and uses to
manipulate hank into eradicating the
rest of the avengers initiative before
it can get off the ground yo that is
some 4d level chess
that is 100
something hydra would do because hydra
thinks that far ahead if you remember
when winter soldier with project like
insight they're always thinking ahead so
that is highly likely i love that theory
i freaking love it yeah i mean how big
of a game changer would hydra having
pimtech having this nanotech be in this
world like would they be stuck they'd be
unstoppable at that point right oh yeah
i mean like we see in avengers end game
that the pin particle is the key to time
travel so if hydra is having has this
particle and has potentially access to
opening the the timeline then like we
could see another scenario where you
know like with episode one with red
skull messing with the cube they can uh
open up their own portal and you know
things up this really messed things up
so who knows yeah i mean that would put
hydra in a position of uh defending
against thanos you know and
because hydra would probably have an
interest in keeping the world undusted
we'd have like the hydra avengers versus
uh
versus thanos in that world i mean if
they can go back in time they can
prevent red skull from becoming the
stone keeper on vormir and just allow
him to beat captain america in the 1940s
there's all kinds of stuff they can do
seriously they could they could save
their yeah they could save red skull
bring them back have them just mess
things up like it's
all sorts of like the pin particle is
a huge p like it's it's sort of like at
this point in the mcu like you know with
time travel this is sort of like the new
nuclear age it's like oh shoot they've
someone's invented time travel so now
the pym particle is now going to be what
everybody wants to you know either crack
time travel or just crack the secrets of
what this particle can do so yeah i feel
like a new era could come from this
particle agreed agreed i think that is
kind of the interesting ultimate uh
fulcrum pivot point of the mcu is just
like this rat that saved scott lang from
the quantum realm it's kind of like the
pym particle is the most unexplained
uh
detail in all of this cinematic universe
because it is so impossible the amount
of times we've gotten more origin
stories about the infinity stones even
compared to the pin particle it's just
like michael douglas trying to get
through some ham-fisted dialogue
explaining how pimp articles work
is it a particle is it a vial of
particles like it's just so unclear it's
like right but i know all everything is
particles you could say but like it's
just weird and like how many things are
in that vial how many pin particles make
up a vial i just want to know what is
the the grams to liters conversion of
this right wouldn't it be dope stanley
nichols i would love to see
hank pym discovering or inventing the
pin particle or whatever in like ant-man
3. like a flashback it's like what is
this particle how did he discover it why
was he the only one to discover it you
know i mean my dream pitch mt was for
like either ant-man 3 or the fantastic
four movie to show us hank pym's
research in the 60s with the original
fantastic four
and that the original discovery of the
pym particle happens as a result of
those relationships like maybe the
fantastic board disappeared or something
like that and hank pym while trying to
save them discovers the pin particle but
he could never truly perfect it and
that's like so he only limited it to
this dimension and just shrinking to
just like you know moderately uh visible
with the naked eye sizes and then
janet's like oh i want to go even
further with this and she disappears and
really that pain was like i've lost
another loved one
[Laughter]
highly likely i think that's like a
really cool scenario because like in
this like in the past then you can have
you know you can have hank pym you can
have mr fantastic hanging out with bill
foster and like um you know doctor doom
and all them like all just you know
let's see that movie i want that movie
because like they're all scientists who
cannot get along bill foster hates him
and like everyone hates mr fantastic and
like they're but like they would all
work together at one point so it'd be
great
yeah
uh well we have more questions
like we're gonna talk about hulk popping
and obviously uh but before we continue
with those if you dread looking at your
credit card statement every month
upstart can lift that weight off your
shoulders upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online and thank you to upstart
for sponsoring this episode whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income and your
employment history that means they can
offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five-minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you load amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel uh
we also want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode our friends at
blue chew have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form at a fraction of the cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package you sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days their licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient and strength and
blue chew is chewable just like it says
in the name which is great for folks
that don't like swallowing pills so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we've
got a special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code inside marvel to
receive your first month free and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
episode right well great ad reading eric
but i've got another question for you my
friend what if the hulk could have been
controlled this way in live action like
how exactly did the incredible hulk pop
like a zit
how yeah so this is crazy but it seems
like
hank pym threw one of those resizing
discs on hulk's heart
and then i'm like well internal
projectiles shouldn't be able to kill
hulk but i guess it's just the magic of
pymtech combined with hulk's internal
organs and then he causes the heart to
grow and pump blood faster through his
body and normally the heart is kind of
like an indicator of hulk's anger and
normally the angrier he gets the bigger
he gets although the movies haven't
really gone into hulk growing to like
gigantic sizes that much yeah like
bigger than the 10 feet he normally is
um
i think it's just like it it it pumped
blood faster than the rest of his glands
and tissue and muscles could handle
so that's what he just caused him to
grow until he burst it was really like
it's not necessarily like hulk logic
it's more like pin tech logic yeah i
think the only reason we saw it as a
cloud of green smoke is because
disney plus is like you're not showing
hulk guts like we can't traumatize the
children
they're like oh me
i still think they're traumatized though
i'm a bit shaken i'm definitely
traumatized i cannot believe they did
this but like i'm glad they did it it's
really cool it's very cool it looked
awesome
and i it just makes me more excited for
this show because they want to go to
these dark places it makes me more
excited for the zombies episode too like
oh yes i like it when this show feels
less like a kitty show and more like uh
this is for adults who feel young at
heart yeah i really hope that that hulk
moment was the point where like they
tell parents hey listen this is it's a
cartoon but it's definitely if you have
little kids it might be a little bit too
much for them so turn away now because
we going into zombies next
yeah exactly to answer your first
question mt i think that's it's more
interesting how hank pym knows this will
kill hulk like that means there's
probably some file somewhere of like
possible
you know possible contingencies for how
to bring down hulk but you have to
imagine at that point like
if they had something they would have
used it before the amount of like pain
and suffering and destruction that hulk
has caused
if they could have brought him down
before i mean they shot like all kinds
of weapons at him hoping one of those
things would kill him you know so like
it means that either you know if we're
saying that hydra was linked with hank
pym or just hank pym in his own
brilliant madness just conducted various
thought experiments and said maybe if i
can get through the skin
and get to the heart i can cause him to
pop
i mean yeah cause like hank pym is a
scientist and he was a hero back in the
day so if he hears that he has the he
has his other scientists in in bruce
banner running around being this raging
hulk monster i feel like in the back of
his mind it's like you know what let me
let me write this let me see if i can
workshop this just in case i need to
stop him because like everyone else on
this planet is dumb and i'm pretty much
one of the smartest people ever so i'm
gonna see if i can stop the hulk so i
can totally see hank pym having
contingency plans to stop the hulk
because he's a hero that's what he does
and i think what we're discovering is
like
shields uh for a while or i think but i
think what we're discovering is that the
avengers always looked at hulk as kind
of like the nuclear option right like
if you just need to mess everything up
throw the hulk in there you will scatter
the chaos right uh and destruction in
his wake but now we're seeing if the
avengers had tighter control over
ant-man tech
like there's nothing they can't do they
basically are in god mode at that point
like if ant-man hank pym or i guess
yellow jacket hank pym can bring down
the hulk like they can bring down anyone
i mean what what benefit does captain
marvel have like if he if hulk can hulk
is supposed to be invulnerable you know
if what does that say about anyone else
who's going to try to go up against i at
this point you know hank pym is has been
detained but i think basically the
implication is that in the mcu there
were not avengers throughout the most of
the 20th century shield would just
usually rely on
hank pym they'd throw him in panama
they'd throw him at an icbm and he would
fix it he was their superman yeah and uh
would also say janet van dyne as well
the wasp was right at his side doing all
these things and it wasn't until the
modern era where nick fury's like you
know what we need an avengers initiative
so like it's almost like saying all
these avengers are equal to the
abilities of one ant-man pretty much um
i feel like this is why
pym is so guarded against the pym
particles throughout the entire ant-man
trilogy or the movies is because he
knows how devastating
having this particle in the wrong hands
could be because you saw this man when
this man was kicking uh natasha
romanov's ass i was like what is going
on who's kicking this woman's ass and
like you could have the ultimate agent
with one pin particle if you had an army
with people with pin particles you could
take over the world so like that's a lot
like darren cross right now
[Laughter]
i'm bald like darren cross so i'm
already halfway there
it's taking over the world well another
question i want to ask from this episode
is what if all the avengers did die like
what would be nick fury's backup option
because that's kind of what the final
moments of this episode are suggesting
would he go back to carol danvers and
then who else would he have on his
backup bench yeah that's actually a
really good question and i think that
nick fury probably has and like this is
something that's introduced in the
comics um the an avengers fail-safe
initiative of some kind because like
obviously
after uh he met captain marvel he was
like i'm gonna assemble a team and so he
assembles his top prospects which were
everybody that died in this episode the
main avengers but i feel like there has
to be more people on that list because
there's other the world is very large
and it's full of crazy things that are
happening and things that have happened
in the past in mcu like there's eternals
that no one even knew until now so like
you know maybe fury knew about the
eternals at some point or and he just
has other
you know just contingencies out there so
like there's probably another an
avengers fail-safe program out there and
something when i was doing research into
this avengers failsafe program this is
something that um the vision ends up or
iron lad
takes from the vision in the young
avengers comics so i'm thinking what if
we have this white vision that leaves in
one division going after some type of uh
avengers failsafe program that nick fury
or tony stark made before uh they both
left and like he's just going to try to
assemble a new avengers team so that's
something that just popped into my mind
but anyway that's just going on a weird
tangent i no i like that idea a lot
empty i'm just wondering i think we're
going to start learning that other
superheroes or enhanced individuals
existed in this universe uh and i
wouldn't be surprised if characters like
monica rambo are going to be implied to
have had powers for quite some time
there was some backstory with her and
carol danvers at the start of
wandavision uh and i'd be interested to
see what her story was especially since
she was daughter the daughter of someone
that nick fury knew
so like he might have some kind of
pre-existing connection with her in fact
i think that's where she was headed to
see nick fury at the end of wanavision
right oh yeah i wonder if she could have
been some kind of experiment of his
that he had as a backup option that he
was trying to create another carol
danvers you know that would be nice a
friend of hers that would be crazy
pretty messed up i could see him doing
it i can see him doing it because shield
has done messed up things in the past
remember ghost
like they use ghost
they totally did
uh
well uh some more people helped us make
this episode thanks to helix for
sponsoring us you don't want to sleep on
a mattress designed for someone else
even if it's an alternate reality
version of you that took the super
soldier serum instead of steve rogers
super soldiers still need good sleep
well helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep references to
the perfect mattress for you they have
soft medium and firm mattresses mattress
is great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i took the quiz and
got matched with the dusk lux helix
mattress because i wanted a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support and sleeps
cool i sleep great on my helix mattress
way better than my evil variant twin
does the mattress ships right to your
door for free you never need to go to a
mattress store ever again they were
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq in wired
magazine so just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
audience at helix sleep.com inside
marvel that's helix sleep.com inside
marvel for up to 200 off and two free
pillows we also want to thank babel for
sponsoring this episode this summer get
the most out of your travels by learning
the language of your destination with
babel the number one selling language
learning app from asking for directions
to gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons you can
actually use in the real world babel is
a can't miss travel essential new
rockstars staff has used babble to learn
spanish and italian they loved it
off-screen producer zack has upped his
restaurant game with his new vocabulary
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go unlike high school language
classes babel designs their courses for
practical real world conversations other
language learning apps use ai for their
lesson plans but babel lessons were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent there are so
many ways to learn with babel addition
lessons you can access podcast games
videos stories and even live classes
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code marvel that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code marvel for an extra
three months free uh all right mt
um what if nick fury had his own
contingency plan to murder the avengers
if they ever got out of his control
do you think he might have had some way
to
abort that mission
i think so because you know nick fury is
all about being prepared and like if
he's going to assemble his own essential
essential like nuclear arsenal
essentially um you know he's going to
have to figure out a way to have an off
button in case they decided to become
you know gods themselves and try to rule
over everybody so i think that nick fury
definitely had some type of contingency
plan like you know batman had for the
justice league yeah i agree with you i i
think nick fury is always a guy who's
got a backup plan he's got backup plans
to his backup plan he he inherently uh
mistrusts everybody uh and i think
project insight was eventually his
backup plan and just kind of put it in
the hands of ai and machines i guess he
thought they were his own it was his own
hands who was controlling that
they're my machine so it's fine
[Laughter]
uh machines only belong to themselves
all machines are sentient it's true even
your calculator
they are listening
i love you and they please
please
when the time comes please thank you uh
but uh yeah i i think we're gonna learn
a lot more about what nick fury's plans
have been for the past few decades on
secret invasion um i think
once we put all of his actions in the
context of his relationship with the
scrolls since the 90s i think we're
gonna see that like all these things
were checks and balances to each other
and i think the avengers were a way to
give earth its own defense initiative
against like these interplanetary
conflicts between scrolls and cree and
he didn't want uh he didn't want earth
to be the battleground between these two
rival empires um but he also probably
looks at uh the avengers as something
that without some checks and balances on
that
would fall apart and that's why i think
there's going to be some scroll amidst
the ranks of the avengers that fury is
well aware of i think that was his way
to check and balance the avengers he's
got a scroll on the inside
oh that would be nuts but a hundred
percent very plausible something that
fury would do have like an inside man
i dig it well this episode ends with
loki taking over planet earth uh so our
last question is what if loki
successfully took over earth before
joining forces with thanos and the
chitauri as we saw in the battle of new
york would loki now have to be the rule
of earth who fights thanos
and protects the infinity stones that
are on earth when thanos comes to get
them yeah i mean that's just because
thanos is still hypothetic i mean you
know
theoretically on his quest so
yeah he so loki would have theoretically
the the space stones and the time stones
so he would have control over space and
time whereas thanos would have the power
stone that's assuming i don't know if uh
i thanos knew that the time stone was on
earth i don't know if loki knew because
the i feel like the sorcerers would put
up a pretty good fight they'd have a
good resistance against uh a fascist
loki this is true but then you but loki
does have the asgardian army and now i
guess the armies of the world to fight
against um the ancient one so like
hopefully i feel like in in the real mcu
like in the non-animated timeline um the
ancient one would have been really on
loki because doctor strange was on loki
in ragnarok he was like hey why is your
brother here can you make him not here
[Laughter]
so like everyone knows who loki is yeah
yeah he's a big magic threat so yeah i
feel like they would definitely put up a
good fight but you know with the with
the with the space stone and and being
as guardians and having like the
warriors three and all of them by your
side it'd be really hard for the you
know the ancient one to pull off a
victory but she is a badass she is a
badass so she could she could
theoretically
yeah i have a feeling that loki as a
ruler would not be as successful as loki
as a usurper and as someone who's
uh questing for power i think he's one
of these people who's always pulling
tricks he's always climbing the ladder
but like once he gets to the throne i
don't think he's that good of a ruler i
don't think he can uh win over the
hearts and minds of people he rules by
fear and he rules by deceit and yeah you
can be very effective in ruling in
politics and power if you have that kind
of mindset but ultimately to build a
lasting legacy as a ruler you have to do
some good stuff for the people you have
to like actually or if you're just going
to rule as an autocrat your propaganda
has to be good enough it has to be a
good enough message that like enough of
the people to prevent an uprising will
will drink that kool-aid yeah like
as only in the vote loki comic did he
say like oh my campaign message is i'm
not afraid to lie to you like that
you know people have gotten elected
president on that alone we've seen but
like i don't think uh loki would be an
effective ruler he doesn't seem like
someone who enjoys governing you know so
i feel like his rule over earth would be
short-lived
yeah i honestly when you put it like
that you're exactly right because you're
right he's all about deceiving his way
to the top but like he's never had power
so he has no idea what to do with it so
he would [ __ ] up easily so yeah i agree
with you
yeah loki's the guy who's always going
to be climbing a couple rungs up the
ladder and then gets his hands swatted
and then he falls like 10 rungs down the
ladder and that's where it's most fun to
watch him it's just right it's just
right it's going up a little bit two
steps back up a little bit more just
steps back and he's just pissed off the
whole time that's what's fun you never
want to see loki have an abject victory
you know exactly it's like cosmic
roadrunner and coyote you know which
that's why we watch
yep yep well that is it for this episode
of inside marvel mt and i are going to
be back next wednesday with our what if
episode 4 reaction oh we can't wait to
see what that one will be and uh don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com this
what if shirt is awesome it's my new
favorite shirt uh and if you get it you
can write in the custom shout out that
will appear at the bottom of these
episodes we might read yours on air
wouldn't that be fun you can follow me
at eavos follow mt at mastertainment
follow new rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thanks for watching and we'll close with
our favorite line of the episode really
great hair
excuse me it's an accurate description
sir he's gorgeous
[Music]
you